as we've been reporting and you've no
doubt been experiencing the
coronaviruses dramatically changing our
everyday lives we continue now our
series on the new normal looking at how
those changes will affect the way we
work
socialize learn and vote right now we're
looking at technology that may help
reopen the economy and keep us safe at
the same time many businesses are
turning to thermal imaging cameras the
devices scan temperatures from a safe
distance and if they detect an elevated
temperature companies can deny a person
entry or require additional screening
our national correspondent Rica Duncan
shows us how this could help stop the
spread of the virus city farmer's market
in Georgia uses cameras like this to
scan customers temperatures as they
enter the store if a customer's
temperature is above 100 point 4 they
are given a flyer that asks them to
leave to protect others but the store
does offer to do their shopping for them
the biggest advantage to infrared
cameras is and measure temperature
without being close to the individual
Chris Boehner is the director of global
business development at FLIR Systems a
company that has been producing these
cameras since the SARS epidemic in 2003
that's when the technology gained
widespread use in Asia the key is that
application is not about an absolute
temperature measurement it's more about
detecting those individuals with
elevated body temperature higher than
the last 10 people that have been
screened fever is one symptom of the
corona virus and many are hopeful that
technology like this will help us safely
return to work what we're seeing is
there'll be a new normal that went for
thermal screening as a frontline tool
since the outbreak dozens of companies
have started manufacturing these cameras
for use across industries and airports
health care centers and even apartment
buildings in New York do you see any
privacy concerns is this sort of
creating a surveillance culture if
you've seen a thermal image you can't
really detect exactly who that
individual is we aren't really focused
on collecting data of any sort it's more
about as a screening tool a screening
tool that he cautions is
just the first step thoroughly renovated
body temperature only one part of what
needs to be a comprehensive environment
health and safety program for these
businesses it doesn't detect fever it
doesn't detect coronavirus we detect
elevated body temperature so it plays a
critical role in that system but is only
one part for CBS this morning
Jericka Duncan New York joining us to
discuss how thermal imaging and other
technologies could change our daily
lives is CBS News contributor Nick
Thompson he's editor in chief of Wired
and joins us from upstate New York Nick
welcome can you talk about how thermal
imaging actually works and is it a
viable option on a mass scale so we all
like and most of that light is invisible
to our regular eyes but if you use an
infrared camera you can see all the
weight room in it and then you can use
math to figure out our temperatures so
you point the camera at our tear ducts
and you can get a basic sense of
somebody's temperature and as Jericka
said it's not diagnostic it's just a
screen but it can give you useful
information if somebody possibly has a
fever and it can provide incentives for
people who have fevers to stay home so
it could be part of a solution in
figuring out who's at risk of spreading
the virus right it's it's an expensive
option though Nick it cost thousands of
dollars
so it's something probably not a lot of
small businesses are gonna be able to
afford to use especially now right it
will be something you're gonna see at
large businesses and major stores
ideally the price goes down if it turns
out that this does prove useful then it
doesn't feel too creepy people will keep
to work on an edge shouldn't it you
should be able to get the price down
another technology you say could could
be vital in this or smartphones how can
they help us potentially in dealing with
the corona virus yeah when we talked
about how technology can help here by
far the most helpful technology will be
smartphones
then alert you when you've been exposed
to the coronavirus so using a technology
called bluetooth you can set up a phone
so that it will tell you if it's been
near the phone of somebody who has been
tested positive and then you'll get an
alert and I'll say hey sometime in the
last week or in the last two weeks
you've been near someone who tested
positive for coronavirus please take
appropriate action this is something
being implemented in a large scale in
Australia working on it in the UK in
Germany it's been going on for a while
in Singapore I imagine it's going to
come to the US again very beneficial a
little bit creepy yeah
well there's a there's a little and a
lot of creepy going on here on some
levels China is using this kind of
technology to track people who've had
the virus right yeah
Chinese using it to track people who
have the virus it's also using it to
track whole populations I mean this is
the most interesting trade off in
technology right now is that often
privacy is at odds with safety you know
where these walking pools of data were
emitting data whether it's the heat
worm-eaten from our tear ducts whether
it's information about whether you've
tested positive that's going on through
Bluetooth there's all this data that
we're generating and that's coming off
of us and all of this data can be useful
in helping society stay safe it can be
useful in helping to reopen the economy
but it also can feel invasive and so we
as a society is collective are gonna
make choices about where we stand on
privacy versus safety there my feeling
is that we're gonna be choosing safety
over privacy quite a bit in the next few
months well safety is certainly urgent
right now Nick so that's the priority
but you do wonder what the payback is
down the road you say you say that
smartwatches
and wearables could evolve to help us in
this - right absolutely right so if you
think about thermal imaging cameras
which are measuring our temperature and
our tear ducts as we walk into a
building
think about your SmartWatch your
SmartWatch can be measure
temperature at all times it can be
measuring patterns in your temperature
it could be measuring your heart rate
there's all kinds of data going into
your SmartWatch or other devices that
you wear on your finger as a ring you
might wear in your ear there's all kinds
of data that could help us to identify
potential infections before we spread
them fascinating stuff Nick Thompson
Thank You Nick